GET STARTED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING ON TIME
WAKEFIELD NAY THAT ARE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A BILL.
AND YES HERE AND WE TALK ABOUT
SP. FOUR EIGHT FIVE CORRECT.
HAVING REPRESENTED FOR MANY
YEARS HE ONLY VETERANS HOME IN
CALIFORNIA THAT YOU DON'T BILL
AND NOW TO MY DELIGHT THEY'RE
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA SERVING OUR
VETERANS.
I KNOW HOW SENSITIVE THE
VETERANS ARE. TO THE PROCEDURES.
THE GOVERNOR HOMES.
INCLUDING THE VETERANS COUNCILS
AT WHICH I WORKED ON MANY MANY
YEARS AGO [inaudible]
THEY NOW WITH THAT THE MULTIPLE.
VETERANS HOMES THERE'S A NEED I
BELIEVE FOR HAVING SOME MORE
CONSISTENCY.
THROUGHOUT THE HOMES IN TERMS OF
THEIR REGULATIONS.
THESE PROCEDURES ARE ADAPTED
THAT ADOPTED BY REGULATION THAT
ACCORDING TO THE ACA
MINISTRATIONS TEACHERS ACT.
AND THERE IS FOR PUBLIC INPUT
ALLOWED.
BUT THE CHANGES THE THE
REGULATIONS.
I HAVE NOT CHANGED MUCH SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AND THAT WAS
THE YEAR WHEN THERE WAS ONLY.
YEAH BILL AND NOW WITH THE MANY
HOMES.
I THINK IT WOULD BE WELL FOR US
TO TRY TO THE BEST WE CAN
[inaudible]
MORE STANDARDIZED.
SO THAT THE HEHE OF THE AND THE
ADMINISTRATORS THOUGH ARE THE
RESPONSIBLE BUT WE HOLD THEM IN
TERMS OF THIS BILL A BIT MORE
ACCOUNTABLE --
FOR THE STANDARDIZATION.
OF THEIR REGULATIONS AT EACH
INSTITUTION.
AND I THINK THEN THAT --
AGAIN AS A PRODUCT OF JUST
HAVING MANY HOMES --
IT'S NOT TO BEING ACCUSATORY
MANY GIVEN HOME WITH ANY OF THE
ADMINISTRATORS NOT GOING TO BE
DOING THE JOB.
BUT I THINK IT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO ME.
IS TO ALLOW THE VETERANS TO HAVE
THE PEACE AND COMFORT
[inaudible]
THAT EVERYTHING.
IS THE SAME.
AND THEY ARE SECURE.
BUT ALSO WE GET IT WOULD IT
WOULD IMPLEMENTED NOT TONIC
HEALTH RECORD SYSTEM.
THAT IS IT FOR THE ALL OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS AS WELL --
THAT IS THE FUTURE THAT'S
ALREADY UPON US AND HEALTH CARE.
AND THE ADOPTION OF HEALTH CARE.
RIDERS WITH.
INTEREST AND ACCESS TO THESE THE
THIS TECHNOLOGY IF YOU WILL --
AND LEAVE A NEW.
A DIP VANCE'S AND HEALTH CARE
VIA [inaudible]
TELECONFERENCE CONCETTA.
I THINK THIS WOULD BE HELPFUL
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT FIND
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE IS TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY.
IN THE REGULATIONS.
AMONG THE VARIOUS [inaudible]
HOMES.
RIGHT --
THANK YOU OF WE'RE JUST GONNA
TAKE A PAUSE FOR A MOMENT AND
HAVE THE SECRETARY TO THE ROLL
CALL.
IRWIN HERE VOEPEL [inaudible]
YOU CHAVEZ [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
GLORIA MATHIS.
MURATSUCHI QUIRK SILVA
[inaudible]
SALAS.
SENATE INNOCENT NELSON PLEASE
CONTINUE MOVE THE BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I WOULD SIMPLY REQUEST AND I
WILL LET ALRIGHT SAID ANY OTHER
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
THREATENING CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL.
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTERS.
WE THANK SENATOR.
NELSON FOR HIS STEADFAST
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE AS
BEFORE.
EIGHTY FIVE IS THE CULMINATION
OF THREE YEARS OF WORK BY ALL
STAKEHOLDERS THIS BILL WILL HELP
CALVET MINISTER THE HOMES.
AS WELL AS HELP THE
ADMINISTRATORS BY HAVING A
MORTAR.
CLEARLY DEFINED AND STANDARDIZED
SYSTEM OF POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FREDERICK
OR METAL ON THE STATE COMMANDER
FOR THE AMERICAN GI FORUM.
AND THE AMERICAN GI FORUM
CALIFORNIA'S.
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DEAN GOTHAM I'M THE
FIRST VICE PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL OF
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE AND I WANT TO COMMEND
SENATOR NIELSEN FURS OPENING
PARAGRAPH IN THE SUMMARY.
I MEAN IN THE COMMENTS.
IT SAYS IT REALLY WELL.
THANK YOU SIR ARE RIGHT IF YOU
VERY MUCH ANY OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS CAN I HAVE
THE SECRETARY BUTTE PLEASING
ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN AYE AYE
IRWIN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE CH치VEZ [inaudible]
DALY.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS AYE [inaudible] SIX ZERO
RIGHT.
YOUR BILL PASSES THANK MY
MANAGER AND MEMBERS --
NEXRAD SENATOR MORALE WITH THE
S. B..
NINE TWO OR GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'LL TAKE IT --
THANK YOU --
ALL MAKE THIS QUICK DID YOU
ALREADY DID I HEAR YOU MOVE IT.
MOTION AND A SECOND OKAY I I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ALRIGHT VERY GOOD ANY OTHER
TESTIMONIES FOR THEIR FUTURE
MEMBERS HAVE THREE BROUGH
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS REPRESENT
AMERICAN LEGION DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S DEPARTMENT
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDERS VETERANS
COUNCIL.
MILITARY OFFICES SOCIALIZATION
OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
CHAPTERS ON SUPPORT.
AND ANY OTHER.
I JUST LIKE SAY SB TWENTY FOUR
SMALL WAY WE CAN --
SUPPORT THOSE WHO RISK THEIR
LIFE AND LIMB DURING EMERGENCY
--
NUMBER DURING EMERGENCY STATE.
RIGHT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
SUPPORTERS JUST ONCE AGAIN OF
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL VIETNAM
VETERANS MORE --
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA WE
SUPPORT.
SENATE BILL [inaudible]
NINE TWENTY FOUR Q..
AFTERNOON FREDERICK APPAREL.
WITH THE AMERICAN GI FORUM
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT --
SENATE BILL NINE TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH ANY OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL.
ALRIGHT WITH EMOTION BY SOME
REMEMBER MATHIS AND SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL MOTIONS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
IRWIN AYE IRWIN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE CHAVEZ [inaudible]
DALY.
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE GLORIA
[inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE SIX ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS YOUR BILL EXOTIC
YOU.
ALRIGHT WE ARE GOING --
TO MOVE A TAKE A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. TO HAVE
MOTION.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
CAN YOU PLEASE.
THE ROLL CALL.
IRWIN AYE.
IRWIN AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE CH치VEZ [inaudible]
DALY.
FRAZIER OR FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE [inaudible]
XTERRA.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL
TO VOTE ON THAT AND WE ARE
WAITING FOR SENATOR WHEN.
CAN YOU UGH MAKE SURE GET
PERMISSION FROM HER FOR THAT
PLEASE [inaudible]
CEDRIC TEXAS
.
BUT SHE'S NOT HERE YET BUT THE
TO ONE OF RUN THROUGH THE HILLS
--
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
PLACE. TO GET ITEMS ONE TWO AND
CONSENT.
THE SPOKEN VOICE TIME.
S. BEFORE EIGHTY FIVE NIELSEN
WAS TEACHING.
RESEARCH SHE AYE.
S. B. NINE TWENTY FORMER
MURATSUCHI MASUCCI AYE AND THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MURATSUCHI.
WERE CG I
ALRIGHT SENATOR TO WIN
IT -- I HAVE
YOU ACTUALLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE RIGHT.
OKAY.
WE HAVE ANY OTHER --
TESTIMONY AND SPORT.
THAT THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
--
REPRESENT AMERICAN LEGION
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA --
AMVETS DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDER
SECTION COUNCIL OF MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA.
COUNCIL CHAPTERS ALL IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
ANY OTHER TESTIMONY GUESTING
GOTHAM CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
THE VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN JUST NEEDS TO BE DONE.
FREDERICK CAMARO WITH THE
AMERICAN GI FORUM CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY SUPPORTS [inaudible]
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN SENATE.
ALRIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE PANEL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
SENATOR I'VE TO HOUSEKEEPING
QUESTIONS IS SO I CAN KEEP THIS
STRAIGHT IN MY MIND --
AGREE A 100% I SUPPORT THIS I
WILL VOTE FOR IT.
WHAT PERCENT OF BEDS FAR?
MORE EXTREME MENTAL HEALTH ON
ISSUES ARE YOU THINKING OF HERE.
YOU KNOW I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER
FOR THAT --
WAY JUST LOOKING AT ASKING CAO
VETS TO GO AHEAD AND AND GIVE US
AN ANALYSIS I'M YOU'VE GOT
ABOUT.
THREE THOUSAND VETERANS IN THESE
GROUP IN THESE HOMES.
AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE NO WAY OF
KNOWING HOW TO DISCHARGE AND
WENT TO THIS CHARGE AND WHERE
IT'S CAN THEY GO WHERE SHOULD
THEY GO.
SHOULD THEY GET MORE.
ASSISTANT OR NOT.
AND SO WE'VE WE RAN THE SIMILAR
BILL LAST YEAR.
ALL I AM AND IT DIDN'T GO
FURTHER UNFORTUNATELY AND SO
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO GET CALVET
TO SAY HEY.
THAT'S FIGURE SOMETHING OUT NOW
AND NOT.
TOMORROW OR THREE YEARS FROM NOW
OR WHENEVER THEY DECIDE.
TO OKAY BECAUSE THEY'RE
CURRENTLY DOING OF A MASSIVE
STUDY RIGHT NOW.
AND IF THEY ARE HEAVILY ARMED
EVEN IT'S COMING OUT IN TWENTY
NINETEEN NEXT SESSION. TWENTY
TWENTY EARLY --
THE AND THAT LEADS DIRECTLY INTO
MY LAST QUESTION --
IN MY SYNOPSIS IS SAYS REQUIRES
CALVET TO BEGIN ADOPTING THE
PLAN RECOMMENDATIONS BY JULY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY IN THE BIG PICTURE
--
THAT MAY INTERFERE WITH THE
SCHEDULING OF ADOPTING ANY
CHANGES OR UPGRADES OR
DOWNGRADES. TO THE VETERANS
HOMES AND THE WHOLE CALVET
SYSTEM.
SO MY MY ONE CONCERN WHERE THERE
WAS IF WE PUT A JULY FIRST HARD
DATE. ONE CALVET THAT MIGHT
INTERFERE WITH QUITE A FEW OF
THEIR OTHER OPERATIONS AND THEY
ALSO NEED TO REPORT. TO THIS
COMMITTEE WITH THEIR WHOLE
COMPLETE.
PLAN OF OF UPGRADE AND CHANGE
FOR THE CALVERT SYSTEM.
SO THAT WAS MY CONCERN IS IF YOU
HAVE.
ONE HARD AND FAST DATE BUT YET
THE OTHER DATES ARE RELATIVELY
OPEN -- THAT
WOULD BE CONFUSING THE CALVERT.
SO A ASSEMBLYMAN --
Y. THE MASTER PLAN AND OUR BILL
S. B. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN OUR
FOCUS ON THE SAME GOAL OF
SUPPORTING OUR VETERANS HOME.
THE MASTER PLAN ONLY REQUIRES
CALVET TO DISCUSS ANALYZE AND
RECOMMEND CHANGES.
OF THAT THE LA 칩 REPORT
PUBLISHED IN JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN HAS DONE
THAT.
WE KNOW WHAT NEEDS TO BE CHANGE.
S. B. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN GOES
FURTHER BY REQUIRING CAO THAT TO
TAKE UP THE RECOMMENDATION FROM
THE LA A REPORT AND IMPLEMENTED
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY SO YOU KNOW THE
MASTER PLAN WHY WE APPRECIATE
WANTED TO GO FORWARD.
IT'S ONLY TELLING CAO BUT TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION ANALYZE IT AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATION BUT THERE'S
NO.
YOU KNOW TIME FRAME THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR OUR STATE WHERE SAY
OUR BILL IS LIKE.
WE HAVE A LA A REPORT IT'S
PUBLISHED IT THERE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THERE LET'S DO
IT NOW AND NOT WAIT ANY FURTHER.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE AUTHOR.
OKAY A SAW I'M NOT GONNA BE
ISSUING A RECOMMENDATION EITHER
WAY ON YOUR BILL TODAY I THINK
OUR STAFFS --
SPOKE ON THAT --
I KNOW THAT IT'S AN IDEA THAT
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR A
LONG TIME AND CERTAINLY IT'S A
GOOD ONE THAT BETWEEN YOUR
ORIGINAL BILLS INTRODUCTION AND
TODAY'S HEARING THE LEGISLATURE
HAS DIRECTED CALVET.
TO COMPLETE A MASTER PLAN THAT
WOULD ADDRESS EXACTLY THE
SUBSTANCE OF YOUR BILL AND SO --
THIS IS THE IN MY MIND BASED.
I'M I'M JUST NOT GOING TO BE
VOTING ON YOUR BILL TODAY --
BUT I CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE ANY
--
POLICIES THAT DIFFERENCES WITH
YOU SO --
FACT THAT SECRETARY PLEASE TO
THE ROLL CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS --
AND AND IT WAS I'M SORRY MOTION
WAS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER IN
THE SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
IRWIN NOT VOTING.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I CH치VEZ.
DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
MATHIS I MATHIS AY MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS AYE. SEVEN ZERO RIGHT
CONGRATULATIONS THAT VILLAGE
HELP THANK YOU OKAY.
AND WE ARE DONE WITH ALL OUR
BILLS SO I'M GONNA HAVE THE
SECRETARY JUST I THINK
EVERYBODY'S VOTED EXCEPT FOR MR
DALY SO FEW CAN GO OVER THE
BILL'S.
AND AND EVERYBODY ELSE INSTEAD
[inaudible]
WHATEVER
.
MISTER GLORIA WE WILL RUN
THROUGH [inaudible]
TAKING MEDICARE.
S. B. FOR EIGHTY FIVE NIELSEN
GLORIA AYE AYE GLORIA AYE.
AS THE NINETEENTH FOR MORALE
S. B. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WHEN
GLORIA NOT VOTING FOR YOU KNOW
VOTING AND CONSENT CALENDAR
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
THE BILL PRESENTATION RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
WELL IF
.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
ADJOURN THIS